les gens disent mais il est fou quoi
c'est un psychopathe qui est devenu
cinglé et qui annonce la fin du monde un
peu comme en faisait dans leur ville
bon on verra bien c'est l'histoire qui
tranchera comme disait lénine mais n'ont
annoncé ces savez du très très concret
c'est déjà du concret avec ma fille nous
avons acheté cette maison voilà une très
zen d'années parce que nous avons
anticipé le fait que un effondrement
général systémique et globale du monde
puisse avoir lieu
didon vers les années 2025 2030 je ne
suis pas cinq ans près en tout ça fait 7
hectares il ya trois hectares de bois et
4 hectares de prés disons c'est
important d'avoir de l'eau vraiment
toujours disponible si jamais l'eau
courant disons distribués par la ville
ne l'était plus il faut bouillir
mais bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr bachelot
1 et celle ci n'est pas pollué l'apa
elle n'a pas il faut voir du point de
vue bacterial mais le bac thériault une
fois vous lamenter à ébullition y'a plus
qu'à des bouillies pas de problème et
aux produits chimiques non elle est
allée les biens y aura ici une tête
et puis avec un bras articulé de telle
manière que on puisse pomper l'eau qui
est en dessous c'est une pompe n'ont pas
émergé électrique parce qu'il y aura
peut-être plus d'électricité dans 15 ans
mais une pompe à bras comme jadis il y
aurait plus d'électricité l'électricité
est pour le moment en france évidemment
pour 75% c'est le nucléaire mais le
nucléaire sans pétrole ça n'existe pas
et le nucléaire c'est toute une chaîne
depuis la mine
c'est pas au niger ou ailleurs jusqu'à
votre interrupteur pour votre télé ou
votre lumière tout ça tout ça évidemment
c'est ces deux faits avec des camions
toutes les initiatives qui existent
aujourd'hui de deux voitures
quelle voiture école quelle voiture
écolo quelle voiture écolo dites-moi
n'ya que c'est une voiture évolue au
rythme mais vous rigolez mais il faut
les laisser ses ultras technologies il
faut lui il faut des il faut des terres
rares
il faut importer de ces terres rares de
chine etc tesla en même temps c'est un
faux qui fait des tests là mais non ça
ne marchera pas les voitures électriques
les voitures autonomes y aura plus de
voitures en 2040
il y aura quelques calèches avec des
chevaux
le moule mode de transport du futur en
2040 qui 2040 comme ça c'est dans 20 ans
c'est pas les bagnoles c'est pas les
avions ni rapides avions y aura plus de
bagnoles
il y aura peut-être quelques bagnoles au
gazogène au biogaz
bon quelques milliers mais c'est c'est
le cheval en vie mais bon si tout
s'effondre avec qui je veux vivre
eh ben c'est pas avec votre groupe
facebook où il ya des québécois et les
chinois parce que ça sera fini rapide
internet en 2035
c'est avec vos voisins géographiques et
donc les voisins géographiques et bien
c'est dépaysant il y en a d'ailleurs qui
est là qui viennent nous aider pour moi
parce qu'il a un petit tracteur l'est
pour aménager le terrain c'est vos
voisins et donc alors évidemment ils
peuvent peut-être ils peuvent être du
rassemblement national ou de gauche ou
de droite peu importe c'est savez que
vous allez vivre c'est une leçon
d'ouverture et de générosité s'entraider
ou s'entretuer ça se prépare
j'ai quand même une certitude sur
l'imminence de cet effondrement
catastrophique dans les 5 10 15 ans qui
viennent
à ce moment là qui survit il est
probable que par les grands moyens dans
la mesure où les services de base ne
sont plus assurés un sa ville de bâle la
sécurité et l'alimentation l'eau
l'électricité les télécoms voyez encore
récemment que aussi bien l'ined
l'institut national d'études
démographiques que l'onu quelle division
des populations louis vers 2050 on sera
peut-être proche de 10 milliards nom
sera jamais 10 milliards jamais parce
qu'à cause de cet effondrement
hélas je le dis de manière ému et
presque en tremblant hélas ce qu'on a
connu comme hécatombe dans les deux
guerres mondiales nous paraîtra peu par
rapport à ce qui va venir dans dix
quinze ans il ya un effondrement que ce
soit la peste que ce soit l'effondrement
comme je viens dire mondiale qui sont
les gens qui vous empêchent de vivre ce
sont pas les chinois he canton en
bretagne ce sont vos proches vos amis
éventuellement votre famille vos rivaux
pour la survie sont les plus proches de
vous donc la psychologie qu'on a c'est
une psychologie absolument terrible et
terrifiante à
et vous mettre ça en tête kiki qui est
ce qu'il va mourir le premier mois où
mon mari ou ma fille ou mes voisins
c'est absolument terrible madame jeu
j'ai du mal à en parler alors on va
aller voir si vous voulez la forêt
profonde par où on va passer de passer
par là allez hop
alors là vous voyez s'il a plutôt la
forêt de conifères et puis là c'est la
forêt un peu plus mélanger ces tas de
bois c'est du douglas a été coupée voilà
quelques semaines on va le laisser là
pour l'instant on n'a pas eu le temps de
le transporter près de la maison on
n'est pas habitué à penser à ça on a
notre cerveau à la fois individuellement
c'est très difficile et collectivement
vous voyez monsieur macron expliquer ce
que je dis en disant bon les gars
maintenant on va passer dans la
décroissance est donc à partir de
maintenant vous aurez la meilleure
politique il faudrait faire pour essayer
de minimiser et de réduire les effets
l'étal de cet effondrement
ça ferait de faire une politique
mondiale de rationnement de rationnement
vous avez chacun a à égalité parce que
c'est l'égalité
chacun vous avez le droit à dison 40
litres de pétrole par mois le droit de
bouteilles d'huile vous avez le droit à
5 kg de semoule et et 2 kg de sucre
ah bon c'est pas le marché qui a non non
il n'y a plus de marché et c'est fini il
faut une politique on peut appeler ça
une économie de guerre avant la guerre
qu'il faut maintenant vivre qu'en ile de
france par exemple parce que c'est la
plus grande connotation en europe et en
france
eh bien il faudrait que le moindre brin
d'herbe soit permaculture ise c'est à
dire que on fait ce qu'on appelle les
paysages comestibles des forêts jardins
et que partout que ce soit la pelouse
des invalides que ce soit dès que la
moitié des rues de parer de bain double
pari soit des pavés ou dépit du mai et
alors qu'on met de l'humus et puis qu'on
comprend face des jardins mais pas au
sens des petits jardins bio partager
qu'on voit dans certains quartiers comme
ça pour faire de la pédagogie les petits
n'enfants sa série c
c'est intéressant du point de vue
pédagogique mais c'est pas du tout la
hauteur du problème la hauteur du
problème c'est qu'il faut faire
massivement une conversion de la
politique agricole commune
vous culpabilisez vous d'avoir eu
l'argent c'est une belle maison d'une
part non on ne vous avez raison on l'a
fait avec les économies de ma fille
puisqu'on et c'est pas copropriétaires
en étant une propriété en indivision pas
mais on a eu la possibilité en effet de
trouver ça ça veut pas dire que l'on va
pas y passer non plus mais bon au moins
se dit on essaie de montrer des exemples
disons d'écovillages de résilience de
résistance alors avec les voisins avec
le jeu ne nie pas le nom parce qu'on
n'aurait pas que les gens sachent qu'on
habite longtemps peu importe avec les
gens du canton voisin
et si on peut monter un éco village de
résilience de résistance et deux d'entre
aide
et bien c'est très bien c'est ce qu'il
faut faire chacun là où on est
évidemment quand elle est dans la dendre
si vous êtes dans le 2e arrondissement
de paris même s'il ya un maire écolo que
j'aime beaucoup ça va pas le faire